a voicemail number two one nine two
david p this voicemail relates to I
guess recent comments I made about
former Green Party presidential
candidate Jill Stein let's take a listen
hey David it's too late you you're gonna
happen to you a whole segment on the
Green Party and why you believe Jill
Stein is completely confident
the internet has spoken
right i I don't I've talked about Jill
Stein before I especially now I don't
know that it's really that valuable to
spend time talking about why I didn't
support Jill Stein I talked about it
during the election we've heard
disagreements from members of our
audience with me we've heard agreements
from members of our audience with me and
I just don't know that we're going to
learn that much more if I again talk
about Jill Stein and I just don't think
she deserves any more attention than the
few seconds I gave her up until right
now even though the caller is demanding
it yeah from that voicemail and saying
the internet has spoken I think there is
no more Jill Stein talk on the David
Pakman show until the next time I have
to remind you that voting for hers are
really bad idea put that on the list
subjects not to talk about please add it
yeah exactly because we're self
censoring here that's that's the new one
on the bonus show today a Pizza Hut in
Jacksonville Florida told employees
fleeing from Hurricane Emma that they
might be punished for skipping shifts as
a result of the mandatory evacuation or
wait mandatory or just recommended
evacuation action bill don't remember
now anyway we'll talk about it on the
bonus show also Fox News's Brian
Kilmeade
compared monuments to the victims of
9/11 two statues that are statues of
Confederate generals from the Civil War
what exactly was in his frosted flakes
that morning and lastly it's not healthy
to sit all day really you should be
getting up at least once every 30 to 60
minutes according to different studies
and we will talk about that on the bonus
show we will talk about my standing desk
that I have here and all the standing
that I do during the day at the David
Pakman show studios get instant access
to the bonus show two way
number one membership david pakman.com
slash membership instant access to the
bonus show number two patreon patrons at
the five-dollar level at patreon.com
slash david pakman show also get access
speak to you then